the other thing you can do is you can
move to a state that is going to protect
your ability to make medical decisions
for yourself we used to have something
there was a whole movement I'm not that
old I remember a whole movement my body
my choice until they wanted to stick you
with things endlessly but right here in
the Free State of Florida yeah we're
going to keep protecting people and not
force anyone to do anything here is
Governor Rod DeSantis talking a bit
about that how many of these Jabs are
you going to take you know you the
traditional vaccine you know you take
you take a shot there may be sometimes
there'd be booster but you wouldn't be
taking them every six months I mean this
is a very new thing
um and it's just it got to the point
where to kind of cover up the lack of
efficacy they would do things like
someone with these politicians they
would they would do do the Jabs then
they'd get coveted you know three months
later and they would like tweet out I
have just been diagnosed with covid-19 I
am so thankful that I am vaccinated
against Coke and I'm just thinking to
myself you know if you took the measles
vaccine and then got measles the next
year you would be upset that it didn't
work you wouldn't be thanking the MMR
shot so it's just uh it's just
incredible
Peter one of the things I always talk
about on the show is that when you hear
someone telling the truth it's just
refreshing like you feel better because
I think the truth is so it is such an
integral piece to humanity that you know
it literally as a physiological effect
on you and that's what I feel when I'm
listening to someone tell the truth
versus fouchy you're sitting there like
you just feel this well now I feel
really a hatred towards him at this
point but the truth it will set us free
will it not
right absolutely and there is something
primitive within us that recognizes
truth it's part of our survival
mechanism and like like I said before
that is why it's so important that shows
like yours and people like you still
have these honest conversations even
when you've got big Pharma and the
rigged media working against it it's
really crucial in fact it might be more
crucial than ever to to stay honest and
operate on fact regarding this issue I
mean people literally dying it's it's
hugely important it doesn't get much
bigger than this if you'd like more sane
takes on our insane World check out our
direct message clips playlist and if you
want to watch more full episodes of our
live round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell